ecological fiber 6 lip6 press of
violent provocation of a compromise
if vouchers and in india via
linkedin is crazy europa or else i read
moreau not those who say today
we will not pay for greece we
would prefer to close the  eyes on the
actions of the 100 his greek government
yes we are going to have to pay for before
taxes it is the purchase of our
warships rather than the fight
against tax evasion by itself
electro accident or métis pipeau for a
risk in  done in the same places is
over ringtone reform sow nature e
reader another in fos prophet everything and
europe
the morphological ti-cats in enio
logic in ouchy case he is neither my
psyche washing hands this title is coming
I put some in europe  vertical never
stick to when a true and not right
now
this year the triple chaslerie culture
hope a year per adherent these
partial results terrible aspect kenya simiana is
interested in what our fears and
supporters madam  commissioner you
say that you consult the citizens
but listen to the hymns want to
consult 4
1 17% he refuses the arbitration tribunals
says you speak on behalf of the consumers
but listen to the consumers the
consumers do not want these
private tribunals and they are very
critical  on the titille vira ms
dikshit stein dorothy height of energy
it was you said it madam the
minister the first presidency of
latvia for a first presidency
what an experience and what a performance
thank you or not from the has your house caté
luxembourg took the reins  from the council
of the european union for the twelfth
time we hope that the next few months
will allow us to demonstrate
our attachment to the european integration project
the luxembourgish presidency
does not advocate read greek sites as a
priority hopes that we will find a
solution but we  have neither progenitor to
my art
m